waving at supporters as they climbed off
their flight
at an airport members of yemen's new
unity government returned
days after being sworn into office at a
ceremony in saudi arabia
but the hopes of rebuilding the country
after more than six years of civil war
turned into chaos a devastating attack
on aiden's international airport
and the work of more than a year of
saudi breaker talks
and a deal signed in 2019 now in
question
the government members were led to
safety but analysts say the authority of
the new administration
has been undermined this is a very
strong message
that the challenges are very serious the
challenges are enormous
and the unity government uh will have to
deal with
uh serious challenges on the ground
and no matter what no matter who stands
behind this
explosion i think there is a huge
security breach has happened
yemen's new prime minister moved quickly
to try and restore confidence
this attack gives the government the
responsibility to put an end to the coup
d'etat and to restore the country
and the state again the government in
aden will go on
continue its job supported by the people
of yemen we will never let our people
down
the terrorists never defeat our people
we will be victorious
we will accept nothing but victory
said's government was formed as a
compromise between uae bat separatists
in the southern transitional council of
aden and saudi-backed loyalists
of president abu rabbu mansour hardy in
riyadh
the two camps fought each other after
separatists declared a state of
emergency
and self-government in aden and
surrounding southern provinces
but together they aimed to launch a
united front against iran-backed houthi
rebels
in yemen's capital cena who deny they
were behind the attack
but the bloodshed at the airport is
likely to put any hopes of peace in
yemen
back a long way barbara ngopa al jazeera